salut ben tu te vanter bienvenue dans
touche pas avant alors je vous dis ce
soir une émission 100% tarka aisée roja
sera on va kiffer douvres à l'achat le
concept vous connaissez des chroniqueurs
qui font semblant d'avoir des trucs à
dire qu'ils vont faire semblant d'avoir
vu des émissions et quoi qu'il arrive
ils vont les défoncer et ce soir je vous
le dis mais chez les chroniqueurs sont à
fond la preuve avec celui qui a la base
je voulais aller sur arte mais qui s'est
trompé le bateau c'est pour l'animatrice
de programmes courts favori dans son
émission la plus de pub que moments
intéressants à l'antenne c'est valérie
bella à l'onu
s'accapare il n'a pas de soucis pas
d'arguments pas de fiches de travail
enfin seuls vrais cheveux mais c'est mon
meilleur les clous jean-michel d'heure
alors c'est le dernier à avoir intégré
la bande mais chérie c'est l'ami des
stars
il ya toujours une anecdote douce et si
tous les coups hier soir le gars il a
dîné avec claude françois chez john ldc
le seul et l'unique va bien le cas elle
a une histoire incroyable au début je
leur embauché pour passer des disques et
comme les connaissez rien en télé je me
suis dit ah il faut absolument l'avoir
autour de la kaaba demoiselle calibrée
de galets on voulait un mec très drôle
très beau et très intelligent manque de
bol on n'a pas trouvé
du coup on a pris le premier gars venu
mathieu delormeau
[Applaudissements]
car des piliers de l'émission
et quand je dis pilier je parle d'un
véritable pilier datant de l'époque
gallo romaine
isabelle morini bosc il a fait sa
fortune en allant d'une chaîne à une
autre il a fait sa banqueroute en allant
d'une femme un anneau benjamin castaldi
est là la beauté la grâce la culture il
ne lui manque qu'une chose qu'elle
n'aura jamais une augmentation il s'agit
d'agathon rwasa est le dha quand on lui
demande son avis il le donne quand on
lui demande pas il le donne quand même
il cela pour une raison très simple il
sait pas fermer sa gueule vraiment à
vous mes chers
c'est le moment d'accueillir mon frère
jumeau le chat guignols mais pour de
vrai je pourrais pas le feu pour sûr il
a le nom
[Applaudissements]
or
est touché ça pour moi et je kiffe
comment je te kiffe j'te touchés
[Musique]
franchement j'ai fait un grand kiff de
voir quelqu'un déjà perdu dans un sauna
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais remercier est ce que les
guignols on va vous retrouver sur
comédie pour un best-of sur comédie plus
début décembre avec une spéciale johnny
pour commencer et je voudrais remercier
claudia et julian j'aimerais qu'on les
voit claude gigan parce que c'est des
marionnettistes et j'aimerais qu'ils
vivront travail exceptionnel et je vous
dis mon rêve et les cherry on vous aime
vous avez fait un travail exceptionnel
voilà je veux dire pendant des années
parce que eux c'est vraiment je peux
vous dire c'est très physique
c'est exceptionnel vous avez et le
succès des guignols c'est vous aussi je
voulais vous remercier soit d'être là et
j'espère qu'un jour ça avec moi mon rêve
ce serait de relancer peut-être un jour
même en prime est peut-être mort après
une spéciale est un guignol un jour sur
la xive et ben j'espère que vous le
ferez avec nous si on arrive à le faire
saloperie
bien sûr je remercie aussi celui qui
fait ma voix celui qui a un talent
exceptionnel je laime j'aimerais
j'aimerais tellement qu'ils viennent
nous voir au moins une fois par semaine
qui vient de faire des imitations
ils partent on doit te crois qu'il n'y a
pas une fois par semaine avec nous un
peu là bas parce que je suis occupé mon
chéri
mais attention chez en spectacle et
merci à l'est quand tu seras là un peu
tu viendras noir tient compte que j'ai
l'impression d'être nelson monfort en
direct à wes écouter en direct c'est
incroyable ce qui se passait et j'ai
l'impression que personne ne bosse ici
dans les studios à bout à bout ces héros
tu peux tu peux me faire un p'tit jean
claude van damme avant de partir est ok
bonjour au revoir c'est jean claude van
damme enchanté on se percute un an pour
en faire des chants bretons en faisons
du bricolage
nolwenn leroy merlin
[Rires]